لا شيء اتغير لكن حسابات الناس تغيرت
فالبيت يبقى هو البيت الحرب هنا ولا يوجد
مكان امن في اوكرانيا لكن اكثر من خمسه
ملايين ونصف مليون لاجئ عادوا الى ديارهم
بعد تجديد منازلهم وفق صحيفه
النازحون العائدون ليسوا فقط من سكان مدن
كبرى مثل كييف ودانيبرو بل بعضهم يقطن
مناطقه تبعد 48 كيلومترا فقط من خط
المواجهه مثل بوكوروسكا هؤلاء عادوا بعد
عام او اكثر على الفرار لتعج اسواقهم
بالباعه والمره وتملا اصوات اطفالهم
الشوارع وان لم تطوا على صوت الرصاص
مقداره الخطر الذين هم على استعدادا
لقبوله غير معروف والتكيف مع الحرب ضبابيه
كما دخان القذائف التي ينامون على صوتها
يوميا لكنهم اتفقوا على المرونه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات